fighting shows no signs of abating
government troops are on the offensive
but their Rivals from the paramilitary
units the rapid support forces rsf are
holding ground
caught in the crossfire civilians are
desperate frustrated and helpless
we pray for an end to the Bloodshed
people have been killed displaced
looting is widespread we never thought
this would happen in Sudan we used to
watch Wars in Yemen and Iraq but we
never thought this would one day happen
here
repeated these fires have failed to hold
the power struggle between the Army
strong band General adelphite and rsf
leader Muhammad hamdan hamiti raises
fear of a prolonged Civil War
stand behind our military but we refuse
to support General al-burhan al-kabashi
and Atta they are all responsible for
the war and allowing prisoners out they
have turned the country into a
playground for proxy militias
as violent surges a trip to the grocery
has become fraught with danger looters
roamed the streets aren't militias are
constantly on the Move shops are running
out of food
Traders are hoarding goods and they are
increasing prices to make profits even
before there was disruption and fuel
supplies they increased prices there's
no justification to what they're doing
seem unwilling to negotiate and end to
the conflict International Aid agencies
warn Africa's third most populous nation
could face an unprecedented humanitarian
crisisera